à quelques jours de la première
manifestation nationale contre le projet
de loi de mariage pour tous le collectif
la manif pour tout 78 sur tous les
fronts distribution de tracts
discussions avec les passants devant la
gare de trappes pour rassembler contre
le projet de loi taubira dans ce projet
de loi on prend surtout en compte le
désir des adultes qui est un désir tout
à fait recevable de de fécondité mais on
oublie un peu l'intérêt supérieur de
l'enfant et on va institutionnaliser un
nouveau modèle de famille dans lequel on
va délibérément privé des enfants soient
de leur père soit de leur mère
finalement la procréation médicalement
assistée ne figurera pas dans le projet
de loi les députés de la majorité ont
abandonné l'idée de cet amendement est
pour certains yvelinois le problème
principal reste l'épanouissement de
l'enfant
déjà en voit les dégâts que ça fait dans
les familles monoparentales donc avec
une seule mère en général bon c'est pas
le père qui gardent l'enfant général
alors imaginez vous avec deux parents du
même sexe
je donne pas de très bonnes chances je
sais pas l'enfant je pense pas qu'il va
s'épanouir dans ce modèle là selon un
sondage ifop publié il ya quelques jours
69% des français seraient favorables à
un référendum